these are photos of an island in the  South Pacific the place where myth and  science meet we use explosives to shake  the earth helping us to map the surface  of the island they're dropping bombs  scientific instruments  we're gonna monkey  magnificent  you knew that thing was out here I'm  sorry for your man colonel but if you  want to make the sacrifice worthwhile  get us home with proof monsters exist  your friend there you can put that down  what the hell is this place  that's calm he's King around here I was  pretty good king  keeps himself mostly well you don't go  into someone's house and start dropping  bombs unless you're picking a fight  Cowen's god on the island but the devils  live below us and what are they called  I call them skull roars why never said  that name out loud before it sounds  stupid now that I say just you call him  whatever you want  it's a good group of boys we're all  gonna die together out here  you